ninety-five million years ago dinosaurs
still had to be weary anywhere near the
water's edge
crocodiles with a taste for dinosaur
still lurked in the rivers this time the
only things that might give its presence
away or a pair of eyes and a matching
pair of horns on the bank a little buck
toothed snub nosed creature may be two
feet long prowls it spots a promising
source of dinner a rotting log with its
prominent front teeth it digs for its
prize finally it raises its head and
triumphs a juicy worm wiggling in its
mouth rat car quickly downs its dinner
then investigates another log path
submerged in the river
it freezes realizing its mistake this is
no log it is pancake run perhaps the
most patient crocodile ever discovered
Paul thinks it might have waited with
jaws open for hours even days a fish
swims into the waiting trap but darts
away as the jaws snap instantly shut
pancake rock gapes again and settles
back in for another long wait not far
from shore one of the great lawnmowers
of the Cretaceous a plant-eating
sauropods Uber's up vegetation
Bork Rock has its eyes trained on the
strangely shaped muncher
but the Dino isn't approaching the
water's edge with any ambush predator
like super croc this would have saved
the dinosaur's life this dinosaur will
not be so lucky
Bork rock stocks out of the water and
really hits its stride
it actually balls the animal over with
its armored nose only after the dinosaur
is down do the fearsome daggers of its
triple canine savage its flesh for crack
was a dinosaur's nightmare this this
clearly was an animal that would have
you know caused many animals to run in
fright there have been very few
dinosaurs that would have given this
animal a real challenge our view of the
Cretaceous will never be the same
crocodiles have claimed their rightful
ancient place as versatile vital actors
on the dinosaurs stage in a once lost
world for those who have had a hand in
creating the crocodile time machine the
end results are more than gratifying
either too cool I remember when we
started digging these up in the field
we were pretty excited because it looked
really bizarre but we had no idea how
bizarre they were going to be we found a
whole world of Crocs I think that's
that's really very fulfilling you feel
as though you've gone just about as far
as you can go to bring this animal back
alive
in the end the crocodiles of the
Cretaceous experimented with extremes of
life on land and life in the water but
they refused to commit either way and it
may well have saved them when the
dinosaurs died
they had the ability to go for two years
if necessary without food they had the
ability to go for months without
drinking and their entire bodies their
entire physiology is is pretty
bulletproof
we call them ultimate predator we call
them ultimate survival
you